and finally new rule now that the media
the White House and political junkies
have made such a big deal about the
first hundred days let's stop doing that
a hundred days it's such an arbitrary
number like waiting a half-hour to swim
after you eat or waiting for the third
date to have sex or not having a drink
until five o'clock it's a big setback
but in the case of Donald Trump I will
say this about a hundred days it does
give us enough evidence to ask those
liberals who couldn't bring themselves
to vote for Hillary because she was the
lesser of two evils quite a bit lesser
wouldn't you say now
[Applause]
and now this isn't about reliving the
last election or about my great love for
Hillary which never was it's about
winning the next election and that
begins with learning the difference
between an imperfect friend and a deadly
enemy Jill Stein said of her electoral
rivals
Hillary and Trump to me one is death by
gunshot wound and the other is death by
strangulation
well I'm sure with Trump in charge and a
racist attorney general there'll be a
lot more of both my dear friend Cornel
West said during the campaign I think
Trump will be a neo-fascist catastrophe
and Clinton will be a neoliberal
disaster I don't even know what a
neoliberal disaster even means but
whatever it is isn't it better than a
fascist one have you people lost your
[ __ ] mind
[Music]
[Applause]
now I can't possibly list all of the
lies fuck-ups reversals conflicts of
interest and embarrassments Trump is
committed in a hundred days I'd have to
stop halfway through to shave but
honestly under Hillary would we have
Attorney General foghorn leghorn or
Montgomery burns in charge of the EPA or
Rick Perry guarding the nukes
would she have a cabinet made up almost
entirely of rich straight white men you
know Hillary she knows quite a few black
people Trump knows - I'm sorry three
when we also might have a Secretary of
Education who was smarter than a fifth
grader before the election Edward
Snowden tweeted 2016 a choice between
Donald Trump and Goldman Sachs yeah so
what happened the anti Wall Street crowd
that was too pure to vote for Hillary
ended up putting Goldman Sachs people as
Trump's top political strategists the
head of his Economic Council and our
Treasury Secretary the trifecta
the only people he hasn't hired from
Goldman Sachs are Goldman and Sachs
the tailoring was president now would we
be turning the clock back on the one
issue for which there is no more time
climate change would we be having to
wonder if our presidents love of
dictators foreshadows some kind of coup
here would anyone have to wonder if she
was Putin's [ __ ] and instead of trying
to kick millions off health care to pay
for a tax cut for herself she'd be
trying to raise her own taxes to get
more people covered on so many issues
she wouldn't be complaining it's
complicated who knew she knew
[Applause]
she loves complicated she's a reader
do you really think if just as evil
Hillary had been elected conservatives
would now be in control of the Supreme
Court as they will for decades just wait
until the five to four decisions start
rolling in gutting unions making it
harder for minorities to vote siding
with polluters overturning abortion
rights then maybe you'll join me in
saying to the liberal purists go [ __ ]
yourselves with a locally grown organic
cucumber
[Applause]
and I haven't even mentioned the
insulting the feuding the whining the
tweeting the family would she want her
spouse to be living hundreds of miles
away okay that one might be true and if
none of that has swayed you so far how
about this if we elected Hillary Clinton
finally we'd have a president who didn't
play [ __ ] golf